la fin du xixème siècle au tournant du
20e siècle on arrive à la conclusion que
le premier teria ce n'est plus cette
force révolutionnaire dans à laquelle
bars avaient rêvé dont il parlait alors
il ya deux solutions la première
solution c'est évidemment là c'est le
socialisme démocratique c'est jaurès
c'est berlin en allemagne tout raté en
italie ce sont les rewmistes au fond
charge elle changer le monde par les
réformes vote de la société
l'autre solution c'est la solution
léniniste la solution les demis n'est
pas original c'est une révolution
classique et 19e siècles on change la
vie on change le monde en changeant les
structures sociales et économiques
mais il ya une troisième voie lille
troisième solution qui elle est géniale
véritable solution du 20e siècle on va
attaquer le valeurs libérales changé à
la société à l'économie le capitalisme
ne veux pas ça ne va pas s'effondrer
donc il faut accepter le capitalisme
mais accepter le capitalisme signifie
pas accepter les valeurs libérales qui
sont liées aux capitalistes et ont
détruit les valeurs libérales et les
valeurs marxiste aussi on s'attaque au
matériel il jure pas dire que fasciste
morfales règle ce machisme qui est en
germe à ce moment-là s'attaque au
matérialisme désormais lui parce que
matérialisme c'est quoi le matérialise
c'est mettre l'individu au centre du
monde parce que le libéralisme le
marxisme ont ceci en commun qu'ils
travaillent tous les deux pour
l'individu final l'objectif final c'est
le bien-être de l'individu
[Musique]